[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: The danger
of smoking tobacco
is common knowledge in countries
like the United States,
which is one of the main reasons
why the tobacco industry is
so heavily regulated there.
But in Indonesia, the industry
has very few restrictions,
so it's hardly a surprise
that the Indonesian tobacco
industry is worth $100 billion.
But what might
surprise you is this.
This image is part of a
photo series highlighting
some of the consequences that
Indonesia's unregulated tobacco
industry has had
on the population.
MICHELLE SIU: Hi, my
name is Michelle Siu.
And I'm a Canadian documentary
photographer and freelance
photojournalist.
The photos were
taken in Indonesia
in the capital city of Jakarta.
The children I photographed
were as young as four
to their early teens.
These aren't boys that
are casual smokers.
These are children who are
addicted, who smoke regularly,
and who throw temper
tantrums or fits
if they don't get their fix
and if their parents don't
give them money for
them to buy cigarettes.
SPEAKER: While there are only
a relatively small number
of children that actually smoke,
without government regulation
and measures to educate
and protect kids,
there is very little
being done to stop
the problem from getting worse.
MICHELLE SIU: I was compelled
to photograph children smoking
in Indonesia, because
as many of us know,
smoking rates are declining
in wealthy countries,
such as Canada and the US.
And as a result, big
tobacco companies
are targeting countries
like Indonesia
that have very lax regulations.
SPEAKER: For the
last few decades,
tobacco companies
have taken advantage
of these lax regulations and the
virtually nonexistent taxation
on tobacco, with the industry
spending hundreds of millions
of dollars on billboard
and television advertising,
often aimed at the youth market.
And targeting Indonesia
is paying off massively
for big tobacco companies.
Two-thirds of Indonesian men
of smokers, almost all of whom
took up the habit
before they were 19.
MICHELLE SIU:
Children start smoking
early in life in
Indonesia, quite simply
because it's everywhere.
Advertisements are everywhere.
And branding is everywhere,
especially where kids are.
And the cigarettes also can
be bought and sold easily
without identification.
SPEAKER: Taking a
step back to look
at the scale of the
problem, 60 million people
smoke in Indonesia.
That's about a quarter
of the population.
And according to the
World Lung Foundation,
around half that number will die
from smoking-related illnesses.
With so many lives on the
line, the Indonesian government
has been heavily criticized
for not doing more
to stop tobacco's firm
hold on the nation.
Yes, tobacco taxes
have been increased.
And there is a proposal
to ban advertising.
But tobacco companies have
a trick up their sleeve
to avoid all this, kreteks,
clove-laced cigarettes used
by around 80% to 90% of
smokers in Indonesia.
Kreteks are an
Indonesian invention,
created during the 19th
century as a cure for asthma,
of all things.
Given their
popularity in history,
tobacco companies are
now pushing the idea
that kreteks are a part of
Indonesia's cultural heritage,
putting pressure on the
government to protect them.
And it's working.
Kreteks have lower taxes
imposed on them compared
to Western style cigarettes.
And there are even
proposals to promote kretek
through festivals to celebrate
their cultural significance.
Tobacco's grip on
Indonesia doesn't
look like it's going
away anytime soon, which
is why Michelle was compelled
to take photos of the most
innocent victims in this fight.
MICHELLE SIU: That
first experience
of seeing this little
kid smoke really provoked
that feeling of heartbreak.
And then in researching
the story further
to understand, OK, why are
these children smoking,
and to understand that there
is an economic and political
driving force behind this
addiction, that made me angry.
And that made me really want
to try and tell the story,
and to let people know
what is happening.
I think it's an issue that's
going to really affect
the generation to come.
SPEAKER: Another issue affecting
children in the developing
world is child labor.
To find out more,
check out this episode.
Poverty is the
driving factor that
causes families to
send children to work
in hazardous and low wage
jobs, such as brick chipping,
construction, and waste picking,
instead of attending school.
As always, thanks for watching,
and don't forget to subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]